it might seem necessary at the outset to
say more about the method of this
movement that is of science but its
notion is already to be found in what
has been said and its proper exposition
belongs to logic or rather is logic for
the method is nothing but the structure
set forth in its purest sense reality we
should realize however that the system
of ideas concerning philosophical method
is yet another set of current beliefs
that belongs to a bygone culture if this
common sounds boastful or revolutionary
and I am far from adopting such a tone
it should be noted that current opinion
itself has already come to view the
scientific regime bequeathed by
mathematics as quite old fashioned with
its explanations divisions axiom sets of
theorems its proofs principles
deductions and conclusions from them
even if it's unfitness is not clearly
understood little or no use is any
longer made of it and though not
actually condemned outright no one likes
it very much and we should be
sufficiently prejudiced in favor of what
is excellent to suppose that it will be
put to use and will find acceptance but
it is not difficult to see that the way
of asserting a proposition adducing
reasons for it and in the same way
refuting its opposite by reasons is not
the form in which truth can appear truth
is its own self movement whereas the
method just described as the mode of
cognition that remains external to the
material
hence it is peculiar to mathematics and
must be left to that science which as we
have noted has for its principle the
relation of magnitude a relationship
alien to the notion and for its material
dead space in the equally lifeless
numerical unit this methods who in a
looser form that is more blunted with
the arbitrary and accidental may retain
its place as in conversation or in a
piece of historical instruction designed
rather to satisfy curiosity than to
produce
knowledge which is about what a preface
amounts to in ordinary life
consciousness has for its content items
of information experiences concrete
objects of sense thoughts basic
principles anything will do as a content
as long as it is ready to hand or as
accept it as a fixed and stable being or
essence sometimes consciousness follows
where this leads
sometimes it breaks the chain and deals
arbitrarily with its content behaving as
if it were determining and manipulating
it from the outside it refers the
content back to some certainty or other
even if only to the sensation of the
moment and conviction is satisfied when
a familiar resting place is reached
we come now in section 48 finally to the
very end of Hegel's long and quite
involved criticisms of mathematical
cognition and he's wrapping these things
up he's made a lot of criticism so far
and you can see them in the previous
discussions in the videos pertaining to
the earlier sections here he begins this
paragraph by highlighting the connection
between we're going to become two of his
major works or sets of works there's
actually two to the Galleon logics
there's a science of logic and then the
Encyclopaedia logic science of logic is
is following pretty close
after the phenomenology and the
Encyclopaedia logic will come a bit
later now what he says is that there's
an intrinsic connection between the type
of work that he's doing in the
phenomenology and the type of work
that's going to be demanded in a logic
so let's look at what he says he says it
might seem necessary to say more about
the method of this movement that is
method of science but it's notion is
already to be found in what has been
said you notice I don't have that word
notion up here because it's involved in
both of those but if it's notion is
already to be found what has been said
in its proper exposition belongs to
logic so if we wanted to create
something like a synoptic almost
textbook like although that there's a
look you know a little bit of trouble
doing that with Hegelian dialectics
overview of everything where you can see
where everything fits in then you want a
logic you you're looking at the method
you're looking at the the structure of
everything on the other hand if we're
supposed to be participating in
something more dynamic more explicitly
dynamic which is intrinsically occurring
through time then we want what we're
looking at right now the phenomenology
which is about consciousness if you
remember we've talked about all these
shapes of consciousness and the
development over time the process of
self movements of uttering relating
oneself to another all these sorts of
things fit into a progress that occurs
in time and you have to go along for the
ride I'm getting a lot of questions by
the way about people getting stuck on
one one paragraph one part of the
prophecy it's very important to remember
that Hegel is telling you in the preface
this is a preface it's not supposed to
be the entire work he said that from the
very beginning you're gonna have to
actually go through the entire work to
see how all the movements fit in
together and there's a lot of things
that probably won't make sense for the
first time reader of Hegel or even
second third time until you you go
through the whole phenomenology or at
least part way through it and you see
how things fit in certainly far past the
preface so there's a connection between
structure or a presentation and you
might say the narrative or the the
history or the the just the story of
consciousness and its development so he
says the method is nothing but the
structure set forth in its purest sense
reality and then he pauses and he's
going back to the discussion of
mathematical cognition and here he's
going to distinguish what we could call
the mathematical form the way of putting
things in in this moment of presentation
the logical presentation and as well as
the the content the the matter what it
is that that mathematics deals in and
both of these are going to turn out to
be inadequate
before we actually go into them I want
to stress something since we are talking
about development so Hegel is
criticizing something that is
particularly modern as a matter of fact
you can say that one of the
central features of the early modern age
was this reliance on mathematics seeing
that all the progress that was going on
in mathematics might be able to provide
a model for how to organize the
development of our thinking and there
were some advances that took place
here's where Hegel it is in a certain
respect if not postmodern at least late
modern he's saying that's all great but
you can't mathematize everything and the
way in which this is being worked out
say for example in you know the great
Cartesian Spanos if you look at his
ethics he's using a very geometric mode
of presentation so his Hobbes actually
and then some of his works for that
matter that was the the way to do it
back then and it wasn't just a fashion
it wasn't just a style it was seen as
being more rigorous as the way to
actually organize and structure content
so that you could make sense of it so
you know this was progress to go from
earlier ways of organizing things think
for example you know Hegel would
probably we going to say think for
example of scholastic theology and think
about you know some of the great
thinkers in it for example Thomas
Aquinas the way the solar tail logia is
ordered and now think about early modern
philosophy and how at least some of that
is order you know some of the great
pinnacles of early modern philosophy
aren't actually organized in that way
you know for example Descartes
meditations but you know Spinoza is
Hobbes is people were quite enamored of
this this idea of look we can we can
understand everything after the fashion
of mathematics after the fashion of
German
I think there's still a lot of that
going on today the problem is that's not
the the final formulation that's not
where philosophy or you know more
broadly science missions shaft systemic
knowledge that is able to take account
of the very fact of its own generation
it's ongoing development that doesn't
fit well into this kind of framework
this framework can be quite powerful but
the problem is is its static they can't
truly develop and the hiko gives a lot
of you know examples of the
old-fashioned way of doing this sort of
thing explanations divisions axiom sets
of theorems
I forgot theorems up there proofs
principles deductions and conclusions
you know these are all things that you
will find in the way in which philosophy
was being presented and you could say
you know is the presentation the same
thing as the actual development the
working out of it and here's where you
get to a really interesting point you
can speak of a logic of organization and
a logic of discovery and they often
don't map on to each other because
discovery itself is a process that may
in fact turn out to be necessary in the
end Hegel thinks that it is but there
seem to be all sorts of contingent steps
along the way where you know human
choice can enter and initiative plays a
role and it doesn't have to go this way
it could also go this way and you know
you have to chart all those sorts of
things out when you rely on framing
things along the lines of mathematical
models or mathematical knowledge let me
say because they're not really
mathematical they're just sort of
borrowing its its framework
you may in fact be restricting your
understanding of the subject matter that
you're trying to grapple with and Hegel
is making that sort of criticism and a
number of points so I'm going to look
you know in a moment at some of the the
criticisms and he's making but another
thing I want to point out here is that
he also talks about the the matter or
the content of mathematics and he says
why is that not suitable for for
handling philosophy for handling science
you know writ large for handling truth
well because what does mathematics deal
in it deals in magnitude which is a
relation but it's a lifeless relation
and it's the most abstract that you can
get so he says it's a relationship alien
to the notion a lien to the development
of conceptual knowledge and what is a
deal n number or the numerical unit and
dead space now we've already encountered
this like I said in an earlier video in
terms of some of the discussions that
are gonna show up in the science of
logic in terms of other categories that
pertain to mathematics you know
continuity the ability to pick something
out discreteness here he's thinking of
it in terms of the numerical unit and
space which is carried out in terms of
dimensions but has nothing determinate
about it so now let's actually look at
what what he's saying you know we could
put it over here if we wanted to I
suppose and I may in fact do that with
with a few of these he says first off
when it comes to this way of presenting
things it's old-fashioned now that's not
to say that we should reject it just
because it's old-fashioned because we
don't wanna just be a bunch of
philosophy fops or something along those
lines
what made it old-fashioned well he tells
us
even if it's unfitness is not clearly
understood little or no use is any
longer made of it and though not
actually condemned outright no one likes
it very much people have have worked
with it and they figured out what you
can do with it and you know for a lot of
purposes it's not particularly useful
and people can have a sense of that and
so they're doing other things that don't
really fit this model and here we're
talking about the development of German
idealism and great permit in philosophy
that's taking place not only in idealism
but also in in other thinkers of the
late you know 18th and early 19th
century Hegel saying look this was the
way to go back in the time of you know
early 1600s all the way through the mid
1700s but that really isn't the way to
go anymore people have started to get a
vague sense of this now that by itself
maybe those people are wrong so let's
look at the the more substantive
criticism he says truth is its own self
movement whereas the method just
described in the mode of cognition that
remains is the motive cognition that
remains external to the material so the
big problem here is how can truth be
articulated that's you know the question
of logic again how can truth be
articulated when part of the nature of
truth is that it's actually reflexive it
is self moving it's not just something
static that you can leave there and then
we're gonna dive into you know a nice
handy taxonomy or something like that we
need some sort of way of presenting
things way of thinking things it could
even just be watching what happens in
paying close attention that can be
adequate to this this facet of truth
that we've come to realize that Hegel
sees is absolutely central we can't have
something that's external to it we need
to
enter into the internal 'ti of truth we
need to realize that we are ourselves
wrapped up in this process this is a
view from the outside from above from a
sort of you know pretended transcendent
perspective and that's why it actually
doesn't enter into the material that
it's supposed to be grasping history
human choice passion the development of
Reason all these sorts of things so
that's a much more important criticism
so he says this mode is peculiar to
mathematics and must be left to that
science this is fine for doing
mathematics it's not fine for doing
history it's not fine for doing say
moral philosophy it's not fine for
speculating about the absolute it's not
going to get us where we need to go so
now he says a few other things that I
want to focus on and so we gotta do a
little bit of a racer here he's changing
topics slightly in this in this passage
she's now gone through gotten rid of the
pretensions of mathematical cognition to
do more than what it is actually
designed to do now he says the method to
an elusive form more blended with the
arbitrary and accidental may retain its
place as in conversation so what goes on
in casual conversation do we demand that
it actually measure up to the rigor
that's you know required in a scientific
presentation some people do but those
people are kind of or isn't jerks they
don't understand how conversation works
you know Hegel is really making the
point throughout this entire paragraph
that each thing each mode of
articulation or presentation within its
its own you know limits within its own
objects
doing what it ought to do it's just not
adequate to philosophy so we have
conversation or historical instruction
yeah you know you needn't think
necessarily about a book of history
think about the work that a docent does
you go into a museum there's somebody
there who presumably is you know well
versed in the topic and they can tell
you a bit more about it than the placard
does or you know your app does and you
know if you actually know something
about the topic you can ask them
questions you can get involved in a
conversation but you don't expect it to
be a you know completely rigorous
systematic exhaustive discussion of the
subject material because it's not that
kind of thing so he says these are
designed to satisfy curiosity rather
than to produce knowledge they saw
something very interesting here that's
what preface amounts to so everything
that we've been doing so far is not the
real thing we're still on our way there
and so he says in ordinary life so we're
also looking at ordinary life the
relationships that we have with
everybody else are eating our drinking
our you know sometimes philosophizing
when what we mean by philosophizing is
thinking random thoughts and stringing
them together so this ordinary life
consciousness has for its content
items of information experiences
concrete objects of thought thought the
objects of sense are thought basic
principles anything will do as a Content
so long as it's ready to hear ordinary
life deals with ready to
yeah what's available doesn't mean that
it has to be necessarily available we're
right off the bat but it's available in
the sense that you don't have to do an
awful lot of work to get there and other
people can also have that available so
you can have a conversation you can
actually have the same experience and
then you can start extrapolating from
there
he also says or its accepted as a fixed
or stable being or essence so it also
depends on what's already accepted you
know for instance in America depending
on whether you're in a red state or a
blue state there's all sorts of
assumptions and depending on where you
are in the red state of blue state
there's all sorts of things that you can
sort of take for granted if you're at a
union meeting you can take for granted
that the people in the union think that
unions are a great thing and that
anybody who wants to bust a union is bad
if you're at you know other places you
can take for granted that unions are not
a good thing and that they're actually
causing all sorts of trouble these are
the sorts of things that ordinary life
pieces together the people that are
involved in them and you have
conversations about it's not yet
philosophy it's not it's not at the
level of science so he says sometimes
consciousness follows where this leads
sometimes it breaks the chain of deals
arbitrarily with its content why can it
break the chain and deal arbitrarily
arbitrarily with its content because
there's no actual necessity to these
things the mere fact that something is
accepted as Dogma in certain areas
doesn't mean that it's true doesn't mean
that it's adequate doesn't mean that we
actually should accept it the mere fact
that we have some things ready to hand
think about for example when you get
angry with somebody now suddenly all the
all the past things that they've done
are you know easily coming to light in
your mind that doesn't mean that you
should actually think about those things
or you know assemble them together into
some indict meant to the person we're
able to take these things out or were
able to sort of sit back and critique
them
what happens he says it refers the
content back to some certainty or
another even if only to the sensation
the moment conviction is only is
satisfied when a familiar resting place
is reached so what he's talking about
here he is he reaches the end of this
passage is where ordinary consciousness
goes wrong now why is he finishing up
that way because we might be tempted to
say well you know we go away from
mathematical cognition which was the the
the model previously for what countered
is really rigorous what kind of is
really philosophical
and maybe we just go back to our in our
ordinary life or something like that
because if we lose mathematical rigor
then maybe we're rejecting rigor in
general and we need something a little
bit more loosey-goosey as we say angles
saying no that's not going to cut it as
a matter of fact people are doing that
all the time but they're not thereby
doing philosophy
but we have already pointed out that
once the necessity of the notion has
banished the slipshod style of
conversational discussion and along with
that the pedantry and pomposity of
science they are not to be replaced by
the non method of presentiments
inspiration or by the arbitrariness of
perfect prophetic utterance both of
which despise not only scientific
pomposity but scientific procedure of
all kinds
section 49 is in some ways an
afterthought we're not going to spend
very much time on it at all it's one of
the shortest passages in this this
preface but there are a few points that
are worth dwelling on so he talks about
the necessity of the notion that's an
important phrase there is intrinsic to
any sort of scientific and dialectical
approach to things there has to be some
sort of necessity at work now you know
we don't have a full grasp yet on how
that necessity actually functions it's
clear that it's not the same thing as
necessity in deductive logic you know
formal logic as people are used to it's
got to be something that can encompass
that but also include an awful lot more
so that we can even extend necessity to
things that appear to be contingent
since history is going to be a major
part of this and the way that we're
going to do that is through developing
conceptual that is the gate for the
knowledge think about you know pacaya
'then as meaning to grasp to take in as
a whole that's what's involved in this
this concept or notion that he's talking
about there and in a way it's misnomer
to say 'the odd notion because we're
talking about a whole bunch of notions
that are gradually assembled into larger
and larger holes he says that it
banishes two different things it
banishes the non-rigorous style of
conversation the the actual terminology
or slipshod we just talked about this in
ordinary conversation we don't hold
people to the same standard unless we're
kind of peasants as we would in some
sort of philosophical rigorous
scientific exposition you might say the
same thing but you know some of the
funny YouTube comments some things where
you know you're like man it's a YouTube
video and it's about a joke you you know
you don't have to make a big production
of it but you know there is
there there is that there any sort of
rigorous treatment of something like you
know history or morality can't just base
itself on ordinary consciousness as
Hegel calls it at the same time he says
it does away with the scientific and
here he doesn't mean scientific in the
full sense he means that which prides
itself is being scientific pedantry and
pomposity pomposity when we have that
word somebody's pompous they're using
language with with excessive formality
they're trying to sort of elevate
themselves you know or elevate their
subject higher than it really deserves
and they do so might by using elevated
language pedantry is when you are
treating every occasion as an
opportunity to lecture people as if they
were school children so you know Hegel
saying we got it within things just we
need to find a balance we need to
actually find something that that's
higher than these and can take both of
these in and allow them their proper
places he's not saying let's not having
a conversation he's not saying hey
nobody should do any any science anymore
he's just saying that's not what
philosophy itself is going to do so then
the question is all right so what what
is it going to do how should it work and
we've talked about this before one of
the candidates that people were
proposing was well this appeal to
intuition hey man there's some sort of
like world ground that you can you can
you can't really conceptualize but you
can feel you can get in touch with and
that's what we'll build philosophy on
you got to have a intuition of the whole
you gotta gotta get to some higher form
of knowledge that isn't really you know
discursive there's a lot of ways to
frame this sort of thing Hegel's once
again saying that's not where we're
going to go he complains about
uh turrents per sentiment and
inspiration and saying look we don't
want that when I can replace slipshod
ordinary conversation or science that
can't really be scientific because of
its you know own sort of pitfalls with
just an appeal to intuition because
anybody can have an intuition anybody
can claim inspiration there's no actual
necessity to that that can be shared by
people back and forth if they're willing
to put in the work it's just why you
just open the doors your mind or pick
whatever lingo your life for it
Hegel's rejecting that and he's been
rejecting that you know wholesale the
entire time why he says that sort of
thing despises not only scientific
pomposity its right to despise that but
it rejects scientific procedure of all
kinds meaning it can't provide an
adequate account of itself of its own
development its own relations to other
things and that's that's really what's
going on in this passage